hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we are here for some
cursy
cursy goodness as we examine the key
differences between the jujutsukai sin
anime and the manga which just to be
clear the jujitsukai sin anime is really
everything one could ask for of an
adaptation and the large majority of
changes it does make are arguably for
the better others can be more
questionable some are just plain
censorship and there's even a couple
that are more than a little bit
inexplicable all of them
are fascinating though and we're going
to begin this exploration with a quick
round of gojo dojo a very simple
minigame the rules of which are as
follows within the gojo dojo we have
three challengers hoping to defeat the
mighty satorugojo now of course we
meaning you
and i and everyone know that this is
going to be impossible so instead it's
going to be your job to guess which
of these three challenges is going to
get gojo slapped right out of existence
first should you guess incorrectly then
your punishment will be to subscribe to
the new world review thus forming a
binding vow and allowing regular cursed
content uploaded directly into your
youtube feed meanwhile if you are
correct then you will be given a
souvenir from gojo's travels
so which challenger will fall first make
your choice now and we shall reveal the
answer in
three two one and bam it was jogo
poor sad soccer ball jogo so if you
guessed incorrectly then you know the
thing to do and please do say hi in the
comments below if you are a new member
of the new world association
welcome but the reason why i chose to
bring up gojo first is because that's
exactly what the anime decided to do
probably one of the biggest changes that
the anime makes to the manga is the
order in which it chooses to show events
sometimes the anime will opt to jumble
up events and play them out of order and
other times it will take events that
were presented out of order in the manga
and present them in chronological order
in the anime it's quite fascinating
really but our key one here is that the
anime opens up with the scene of yuji
and gojo
discussing the impending execution so
the series begins with a flash forward
really because this scene doesn't
actually happen until
chapter two of the manga in fact
canonically the very first character
shown in jutsukai sin is fushiguru
however i think that this is a solid
change for two reasons one it
immediately provides a hook for the
viewers whereas the manga in my opinion
had a very slow or like
maybe not slow but definitely a more
humble start it definitely didn't have
me gripped from page one
and there's this really insightful thing
that hirohiko araki the author of jojo's
bizarre adventure says in his book
entitled manga in theory and practice
where he states that the first page of
any given manga series is by far the
most important araki's philosophy is
that it's the first page that
needs to drive someone to want to read
the next 10 000 pages and the same
theory can be applied to anime it is
that first minute of the anime that
immediately sells the entire series of
jutsu kaisen in a far more effective way
than the manga did
in my opinion and then of course the
second beneficial factor is that it
allowed the anime to book gojo in the
first episode and that man is a key
selling feature of jujutsu kaisen all on
his own so a very solid idea there
episode 1 also features one of the
bigger changes of the series which all
has to do with how yuji eats the initial
sukuna finger in the manga this is done
with an almost
like startling level of casualness yuji
and fushiguru are facing off against the
cursed spirit and yuji has the bright
idea to give himself some cursed energy
by eating the finger and so out of
completely nowhere and with no second
thought he just does it right then and
there in the anime this is significantly
more dramatic to say the least because
yuji consumes the finger out of
desperation because he is mere
seconds away from being killed by the
cursed spirit so it paints yuji as more
of a last-ditch hero as opposed to the
manga which
honestly makes him look a bit more like
a [ __ ] and i'm not saying that's a bad
thing either in fact i
really like the way the manga did it
simply because of the way that geiger
kotami subverted your expectations
because you would think that yuji
is going to need to be pushed into that
situation like he is in the anime before
he makes that choice but instead of that
he's just like no need i'm just gonna do
it i'm just gonna casually put it in my
mouth
and it's done and it does say quite a
lot about yuju that he would be so
willing to do that so easily in my
opinion i think that the anime is edging
a bit too much on the drama here in fact
it reminds me of like what every episode
of star trek when the enterprise is in
trouble and it's about to blow up or
something there's always a character
like data counting down the seconds till
everyone dies
and the crew never absolutely never
solves their problems until that
countdown gets to one or zero it's all
artificial drama and to be fair that
artificial drama well it works that's
what the jujitsu kaizen anime did they
had yuji make his choice when he was
down to like
one second away from death as part of
that the anime also extended the action
elements of yuji versus the cursed
spirit which is a very ongoing feature
in jujutsu kaisen
most action scenes in the series feature
a huge degree of elongation and can
often be seen as mapa just sort of
flexing you know
saying look at the cool things that we
can do which i'm actually pretty okay
with they can extend the action all they
want even if it does get a bit absurd
like fushiguro versus sukuna but it
doesn't matter as long as it looks good
and as long as it feels good the one
time where it may arguably matter is
when these extensions change particular
character traits like say mai vs maki in
the tokyo goodwill event in the manga
after maki catches the seventh bullet
mai just concedes defeat whereas in the
anime my husband she has a little bit of
a my tantrum and then repeatedly tries
to bash maki with her gun
which is interesting because i guess it
makes my look more irrationally
desperate and emotional but i also do
like the manga betrayal of just having
her collapsed in resigned failure
because it plays her as wise enough to
know better
you know the anime gives you that raw
emotion which equals more of the dramas
so i guess it just depends what kind of
experience you prefer it's not just
combat that gets elongated however and
one particularly horrifically dwelled
upon scene
is when jogo burns up the restaurant
this event is almost
instantaneous in the manga one big fiery
boom thing and it's all done but in the
anime jogos seems to combust
people one by one almost as if he's
taking pleasure in the act of doing it
like he's making sure not to consume his
meal too
quickly because jojo is a connoisseur
and he needs to have it bit
by bit so as to attain maximum enjoyment
which is super sinister and i think it
makes jogo look a lot more blanket evil
than he actually is
because it is one thing to want to
eradicate humanity to just pave the way
for your new human
cursed nature regime but it's completely
another to take pleasure in that task of
eradication like they're both bad but
one is definitely worse
speaking of our nature-based spirits
though harmony has an intriguing little
difference in the anime being that we
can actually understand them
well sort of anime's initial lines in
the anime are spoken in this like
backwards speak
so if you're quick enough or if you
pause the episode you can figure out
what hanami is saying such as when
they're speaking to ghetto in episode 7
saying we are the true humans after all
which is actually a very poignant
insight at that point in the series one
that manga readers had no concept of
because meanwhile in the manga these
early instances show hanami as being
completely incomprehensible to the
reader we mainly get speech bubbles with
what looks like these is sort of like
hieroglyphics and the only clues you
really get are from the other side of
the conversation whoever hanami is
speaking to
at any given time which more often than
not keeps things very deliberately vague
and this actually leads to a fairly
hilarious situation during the tokyo
goodwill event where hanami encounters
xunamaki which is just great because
they converse with each other but
they're both speaking completely
incomprehensibly enemy with their
hieroglyphic talk and inamaki just
a yelling random food i love it it's
hilarious so it's a shame that those
little things get a bit lost in the
anime but at the same time a choice did
need to be made and speaking these
initial lines backwards yeah
it was fine on the topic of choices we
are all familiar with yuji's jennifer
lawrence-based obsession but there was a
minor change in the anime in regards to
the poster that yuji puts up in his room
seeing the woman it's imply that this is
meant to be a poster of jennifer
lawrence although in the manga
it's a poster of a completely different
woman here we see a figure with clearly
asian facial features and black hair as
opposed to the blonde
assumedly jennifer lawrence-ish figure
of the anime and it's pretty obvious why
this change was made because if you're
going to have a character be obsessed
with a certain celebrity then the poster
containing a different person is a bit
of a missed opportunity in that regard
minor changes like this
are some of the most fun though and one
thing i immediately noticed when
watching the anime were yuji's glasses
when he fushikuro and gojo went to pick
up kugisaki in the manga yuji had these
like tacky new year's glasses that said
2018 and when i read that i was like wow
this is this is gonna date the series
and given that the anime was being
produced in 2020 it felt obvious that
something like that was going to change
but instead of going with the 2020
glasses maybe
out of concern for the year that 2020
was around the world the anime decided
to give the scene a more timeless
quality by making the glasses spell
either the word rook
or rock it's actually it's kind of
confusing because if you look at the
second o it's actually separated and
this o
may in fact be a c the spelling rock huh
but whatever the case may be it's it's a
meaningless word and the change was just
made to ensure that we're not
setting a specific time period i guess
but a fair few changes were also made in
the anime for the purpose of
censorship jujutsu kaisen is actually
pretty shockingly violent series for
ashona manga and there are times when
akitami's artwork is deemed a bit too
graphic for the anime one such occasion
is when hanumi returns after the tokyo
goodwill event having been wounded by
gojo
in the manga there is this very visceral
depiction of hanami's body just falling
apart and even
falling out when returning to the super
evil lair place so the anime saw this
and they went
er let's let's not do that and instead
they decided to creatively censor it by
crafting the strategic darkness around
the wound but also by changing the
camera angle so that hanami's initial
appearance is front on instead of sidon
thus conveying the shocking wound with
all of the missing bodily bits but
without needing to show it as
graphically as akutami decided to but on
rare occasions things in jutsu kaisen
sometimes a little bit
too hot for television and in this case
we now turn to the death painting esso
in the anime he's a pretty scandalous
dude already with his super super tight
black pants
and whatever he's wearing on top i don't
know what you would call it there's like
some sort of
nipple shirt fabric designed to cover
nipples and like nothing else but when
we contrast that to manga esso well he's
a bit more out there to say the least as
there are no pants to be seen
and lots to be seen instead of the pants
like some very central leggings and a
g-string that leaves
nothing to the imagination that's a
bulge and it's one of those cases where
i just find it fascinating what you can
get away with in manga designed for
young teenagers but not a television
series intended for that exact same
audience but something that i love about
jude's kaisen in general are the pop
culture references that akatami throws
in because akutami and i were around the
same sort of generational age group and
sometimes those references are not only
hilarious but also legitimately helpful
without spoiling anything there's a
reference to digimon and the manga that
just like instantly made me understand
that particular situation perfectly i
love it and the anime also embraces this
by
expanding upon these references for
example when yuji is watching movies to
train in the manga it is implied
that one of those films is lord of the
rings you just see his compelling gaze
and we hear the dialogue on screen in
which frodo is clearly pining over sam
but in the anime they went and did a
full-on parody of lord of the rings
showing the scene on screen which i
loved but when yuji is discussing cursed
energy with gojo initially in the anime
he claims that he wanted to perform a
spirit gun a bangkai or a sengon and
even a dodon ray which are all
references to very important media in my
life but crazily enough this line is not
actually in the manga the anime decided
to add this line and it's actually one
of my favorite in the entirety of
judeskaisen i don't know why i just
really like yuji weebing out it makes it
much more identifiable to me and
probably most people who read anime or
watch manga
or the other way around i mean you can
read anime if you want i guess you do
with subtitles you could also watch
manga but
the pictures aren't going to move for
you so it's probably a lost cause but
you get what i mean because yuji doing
the things that we're doing right now to
watch him doing the things makes him
more identifiable wow i really left that
whole section up didn't i but let's
forget about all of that because it's
time for you to decide to watch another
video like this one here there is always
more to learn explore and enjoy about
judeskaisen
so i look forward to seeing you there
and hopefully i'll be speaking properly
but i make no guarantees